the General Affairs Council on the 17th
of March will prepare for the March EU
summit where the main focus will be to
set up the establishment of an energy
union ministers will review proposals
included in the commissioners ng union
strategy a key EU priority the goal is
to make the European Union market more
competitive more sustainable and to
ensure a secure supply of energy the
council will also lay the groundwork for
heads of state and government to review
the first phase of the European semester
4 2015 the European semester is a
process under which EU countries agree
on economic and fiscal policy priorities
for a given year the blocks leaders are
expected to provide guidance to member
states for the preparation of their
national reform and stability or
convergence programmes finally ministers
will review external relations issues
ahead of the leaders meeting these will
include preparations for the may 2015
Eastern Partnership summit in Riga as
well as relations with Russia and the
situation in Ukraine regarding the
latter talks will focus on the
implementation of the Minsk agreement
and possible further steps the situation
in Libya has implications for the
security of the European Union is also
on the agenda